[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and the co-host of pro football talk
live celebrating the 20th year of pro
football talk he is mike florio back on
the program all right mike we knew that
uh beckham was going to be released now
can you explain the process here of him
going to uh on to waivers and then what
happens after that
yeah dan after the trade deadline any
player no matter how many years in the
league must pass through waivers if
released if this happened a week ago
he'd be able to go anywhere he wants it
happens now he's got to go through
waivers and what i'm going to be curious
to see is what they exactly did to his
contract the browns wanted to reduce
their financial obligation to him moving
forward
but there's a sweet spot there because
if you make it too attractive
then one of these other teams says we'll
just claim the contract on waivers
beckham wants to be a free agent for the
first time in his career so that's what
to watch during the waiver period that
window will open once he's officially
released presumably at 4 pm eastern
today teams will have the ability to
make their waiver claims and then we
just have to wait and see what the
results are all it takes is one team one
team claims him he goes to that team
whether he wants to or not and how does
it start with the pecking order of the
lions are on the clock for odell beckham
correct that's right there's an order
that gets updated every week during the
regular season after the third week is
when it starts to change it's locked in
going into the season for the first
three weeks after week three every week
it's updated the lions as the only
winless team have dibs and then you'd
have the texans and the dolphins and
whoever loses that game this weekend
assuming the waiver period doesn't close
before sunday that team would have
second dibs and so on until we get down
to the best teams that's how it goes and
you don't know what other teams have
done everybody either says yes or no
puts in a claim and then the league
sorts it all out you could have in
theory 30 teams make a claim for him on
waivers but the team with the highest
priority is the one who gets him okay
more likely that he clears waivers or
that he's picked up by a team
got to see the contract got to see how
they have negotiated it
i would like to think his agent insisted
on a structure that will make it more
likely that he's not claimed on waivers
and let me give you a quick example
without getting too far into the weeds
browns want to reduce his salary want to
pay him less okay fine well let's put in
the contract a clause that he gets 500
000 per game
when he's on the active roster per game
roster bonus an enormous amount that
would scare a team off from claiming him
on waivers because that automatically
becomes part of what they owe him
if they take him browns don't have to
pay it but if you take him you have to
pay it something like that
would be advisable if the goal is
to help him clear waivers
who should who should pick him up
well
look i i think the packers should i
think the chief should the chiefs have
been
struggling to find someone who can step
in and supplement tyreek hill and travis
kelsey there are some high-end
contenders out there that should want
him the names that have bubbled up so
far though i'm told seahawks 49ers and
saints the saints already were talking
to the browns about a trade they
couldn't work it out i think the saints
would be very interested in adding him
to the mix my understanding is he'd like
to play for the seahawks and if those
are the three teams that are most intent
in pursuing him seahawks have the best
quarterback in russell wilson once he's
healthy so it would make sense but yeah
there are plenty of teams that i think
should
want to see what he can do the question
is nobody really knows what he can do
yeah he's been open a lot this year but
are defenses really
paying attention to them the way they
used to i don't think so
what if baker mayfield is the issue
well
if he is the browns have chosen baker
mayfield over odell beckham jr and dan
when they did the trade
out of the blue march of 2019 my first
reaction was cleveland is a town that's
not big enough for both baker mayfield
and obj and i remember when
the off-season program started in april
of that year and everyone was there for
the first day they did the press
conference with obj and mayfield and
jarvis landry who's been close with
beckham dating back to their days at lsu
and then mayfield
has to like be there as the quarterback
after obj just walks out the door and
disappears for the offseason program
that's your opportunity to build
chemistry to get to know a guy and obj's
nowhere to be seen i think that threw a
wrench into it early on the pressure to
constantly get the ball to obj i think
mayfield resented that he's the
quarterback he makes the decision as to
who's open and where the ball goes and i
just don't think it ever really got them
on the same page he's mike florio pro
football talk live co-host the aaron
rodgers situation
um
how complicit is the team in this
situation was there a cover-up
you know is aaron rodgers going to be
suspended maybe fine uh go ahead pick
pick one of those questions
literally there was no cover-up because
he repeatedly did press conferences in
the facility without his face cover
and and and this is what's strange about
the covett protocols dan and a lot of
teams are watching this because the
league has a history of being selective
in its enforcement of rules
last year a handful of teams got
hammered for coaches not properly
wearing masks when a lot more coaches
than the ones who got hammered weren't
wearing masks so there's teams out there
that repeatedly land on the nfl's radar
screen like the saints and the patriots
who are wondering what are they going to
do to the packers here right
what are the emails look like between
jeff pasch and mark murphy the ceo of
the packers how friendly are they is he
going to look the other way has he been
looking the other way and there's no
denying it
when it's in plain sight
he's at press conferences they know he's
not vaccinated and there isn't a mask on
his face preseason games he was on the
sideline not in uniform no mask i read
the protocol as being very clear
only active players are exempt from
wearing a mask during a preseason game
if they're not vaccinated and the
league's already twisting itself into a
pretzel to excuse it because they let it
happen that's the real question here
they rely on the teams to enforce the
covet protocol but then the league
you know they can see the same press
conferences we see
why wasn't the league saying to the
packers are you finding this guy 15
grand a pop
for not complying because he clearly
went in the public eye
was going to keep the masks away because
he wanted to perpetrate the rules that
he was actually vaccinated and yeah it's
where the packers enforcing the protocol
and was the league asleep at the switch
because it looks like both were true
well it feels like the packers and
rogers were collectively winking at this
like that's right you know we're not
going to tell and don't worry and like
nobody wants to upset if you know in
particular the packers don't want to
upset him
like they they need to fall on the sword
here
the delicate genius who decided 72 hours
before the start of training camp that
he wasn't going to retire you think
they're going to antagonize him or do
you think they're going to look the
other way if they can and you know what
this is one of those where you do the
analysis in advance this is the old
saying it's better to ask for
forgiveness than permission let's just
keep our mouth shut about this and if it
ever hits the fan
we'll write the check
we'll deal with it then but we don't
want to undermine our very tenuous
relationship with a guy that we are
trying to make feel good about us what
better way to make him feel good about
it than to not hassle him every day
about wearing a mask especially when
he's in the public eye and he wants to
be able to advance the false narrative
that he's actually vaccinated so doesn't
surprise me at all and that's why the
league should be in charge of this
somebody said to me yesterday somebody
one of the teams said you know the teams
aren't expected to find the coach when
the coach goes to a press conference and
rips the officiating the league does it
why isn't the league the one that's
intervening and disciplining a player
when he fails to comply with the covet
protocol what did you have yesterday
that you posted about roger's reaction
was he was he livid or what was the
curious period
furious now is he furious because
well tell me why why is he furious
well he's furious that he got out that
he's not vaccinated and you know dan
this has been an issue for years but
didn't it have to get out mike if he's
on the covet list that people are going
to go
are you vaccinated
well if he's on the covet list because
of a positive
that doesn't necessarily show that he's
not vaccinated if you're on the covet
list because of a close contact then
you're definitely not vaccinated because
if you are
you you're not knocked out for five days
as a close contact but if you're
positive it doesn't matter whether
you're vaccinated or not
and when you throw on top of it that it
was the nfl's media conglomerate that
reported that he isn't vaccinated and
the league is
nfl media and nfl media is the league i
i'm just i'm trying to anticipate what
his next appearance with pat mcafee is
going to sound like what his next press
conference with a mask on i assume is
going to sound like and he's going to be
looking for somebody to blame look the
book's out on this guy i'm sorry one of
the great quarterbacks of all time but
we know how he is he wants to blame
somebody and i could see him fashioning
an argument that he had the right to lie
to all of us about being vaccinated he
had the right to choose to keep that
secret and he shouldn't have been outed
by the league
wow
i mentioned i can't wait must see tv get
your popcorn the next time he talks dan
uh jordan love do you want him to play
great
or bad for the story
oh i think the story is better if he
plays incredibly well isn't it that
makes it more likely the packers move on
from aaron rodgers after yeah but if he
doesn't play well and you know rogers is
likely to move on and jordan love is not
your future
that could be awkward well then that
proves his point from all along why in
the world did you trade up in round one
to draft a quarterback when we had other
more immediate needs that would have
maybe helped us win the super bowl last
year hey i don't rule out and and and
i'm i've learned through 20 years of
doing this
you have to be ready
for everything and the thing that you
aren't ready for is the thing that will
happen
we haven't heard a word from aaron
rodgers
in the two days since this hit the fan
not a peep not a tweet not a word not a
thing not a statement nothing
what if this is the thing that causes
him to say i've had enough of this crap
i've had enough of dealing with this
league i've had enough of dealing with
this team i've had enough of dealing
with this game i'm out i'm done i'm not
saying it's going to happen but wouldn't
that be amazing if that's what he
decides to do just walks away middle of
the season because he's pissed off that
he got outed for being unvaccinated
again very small chance of it happening
but if you don't account for it that's
when it happens maybe i shouldn't have
said it maybe i don't say it it happens
but i've got everything's on the table
for me on this day and i can't wait to
hear what he has to say
would you put him in front of the media
well he has to be i mean he has to be
and now should he
should he speak
now i just feel like and peter king said
this earlier today on pft live the
silence is deafening and what happens is
when you choose not to speak in the
aftermath of something like this you
allow everyone else to create the
narrative and the narrative is he's a
big fat liar so if you've got an
explanation and i hope he doesn't try to
parse words
and say that immunize means something
other than vaccinate i mean i've watched
that clip you've seen that clip are you
vaccinated yeah i've been immunized and
i'm not going to judge my teammates who
aren't vaccinated
he's telling the world he's vaccinated
by saying it that way and if he tries to
to to navigate the words that's not
going to help him i i don't know i and
i'm ready to have an open mind whatever
his explanation is but the longer he
waits the harder it's going to be to
turn everything around
have a great weekend mike
thanks dan and congrats on 20 years pro
football talk and pro football talk live
you can see it on peacock preceding our
show uh a couple of phone calls in here
floria's all fired up there i like that
he wants answers let's get answers